É hoje pessoal
que eu vou responder
as perguntas que você mais
me perguntam e as vezes tenho que  responder
ola todos pessoal
aqui quem fala e o dark
e seja muito bem vindos a mais um video
e eu hoje tragos aqui um martelo da polemica
um martelo das respostas,o martelo que vocês querem saber de mim
Basicamente sempre que eu responder uma pergunta, eu vou bater com o martelo...
assim
esta fechado o assunto.
Dark, como esta o relacionamento,  com a sua namorada?
E eu vou responder
Dark esta chateado com os Youtube, da casa dos Youtuber's
Vou responder (rs)
com o ipea a brincar mas não vou
responder a todas as perguntas portanto
fiquem até o fim eu vou ser muito
sincero responder a tudo que é tipo não
vou dar aqui com muita enrolação nem é
tentar fingir que as coisas estão bem
porque lembrava algumas dessas coisas
não estão bem mas também mas eles
cruzaram de que o vídeo quer descobrir
muito muito muito lá que me inscrevi
porque o youtube não é dá pra falar de
mim é muito importante para exportarem é
eu não falasse turisticamente falando
aqui é plástico do meu canal disse que
apenas entre 5 é de 10% de desconto por
cento do meu público é que receba a
notificação dos meus recomendados também
estão a funcionar nem nada funcionar
outra coisa que me chateia um é que os
vídeos no próprio dia levo restrição de
idade e no outro disse que não está tudo
bem nesse primeiro dia é o dia 1 do
vírus pouco mais de um ano chega a mais
pessoas portanto alguma coisa está
acontecendo aqui então eu fiz mesmo
muito da vossa ajuda mesmo é porque
vocês acharam lá explicaram que os
vossos inimigos e isto acaba procurando
não consegue fazer nada porque nossa
força ai toalha só vamos fazer um
negócio é eu vou tentar produzir mais
vídeos e mais contido pra vocês ok o
comprimento mas você também tem que
procurar o canal próprio no youtube
agora pessoal nosso estado é que antes
de responder às perguntas de um grupo
denuncia que amanhã eu vou estar no
curto na maia que gostar do evento
sledge não sou eu sou eu e da colômbia
inteira eu biodança beatriz nós vamos
falar nos mais legítimos porque é
pressionada e efeito de julho já os não
já amanhã eu vou deixar toda a
informação aqui inclusive vou deixar
como está' grande porque eu deixei um
pouco vocês podem ver lá informação e
outra coisa o evento é gratuito vocês
podem ir à vontade nas mãos tem que
fazer o nosso registro
embaixo este link é o primeiro nem
descrição faça uma nova cirurgia estoque
podem perder a linha é grande e temendo
vocês podem contar comigo à vontade até
porque não sou daqui tenho de 20 todos
pagos tempo a imaginar um abraço em
tobago número 1 ela não faz isso pô já
começa mas para lá pessoalmente sinto
responder às perguntas é a primeira
pergunta que vocês perguntam muito mesmo
depois de já ter disponível muitas vezes
aqui no canal olha só para que não mais
voltar aos jogos de terror é bom ea
resposta é assim eu tenciono trabalho
mais vendido do ok mas como eu disse o
youtube não está a tratar muito bem o
meu canal portanto não posso arriscar
muito fazer esse tipo de conteúdo que
nem o youtube gosta de se continuar
assim mais preto rolim jogos num tá tudo
muito estranho muito estranho e
basicamente o que aconteceu quando
gravavam jogo de terror o vídeo não é
procurado tempo não dá e por isso mesmo
o youtube acaba por uma cara que ouve o
que não quer dizer que eu não gosto de
fazer e não quer fazer porque eu quero
mesmo fazer mas enquanto isso o brasil
também tem que saber que é muito
estranho que vocês parem de trabalhar e
dedicar a nossa alma é algo que todo
fora mas não faz nada com isso e
simplesmente ignora seu tipo não
partilha por isso mesmo por ser que
inspire pra vocês me ajudarem muito
porque se for assim o youtube não tem
barreira entre nós mas aos pouquinhos
vou colocando mais visto o pessoal não
se preocupem estados unidos
outra pergunta que vocês perguntam muito
daqui onde é que está o como evitar um
jogador doou nós o prendemos foi legal
ver como está o jogador doou mal vocês
têm que perguntar se o ppe preocupe
nunca mais jogou e agora josé fortunati
joga jogar que os jogos estranhos e eu
não sei o que é que aqui é meu eu ajudar
coisas muito estranhas não ser que seja
o começo hoje a nokia entrou o vamos
fazer que o single malt teve 81 pivô
voltas valor pingente tem soldados que
guardam materiais por esse vídeo já tem
tudo preparado já se precisamente o que
eu vou fazer o pior mas uma das coisas
podem já não não posso vacilar vai ver o
vídeo é estupidez op está no estúdio
calma acha acho que tá tudo lá em
movimento que eu venho agora este vídeo
e vai ver que foi uma das pessoas por
twitter
e você tem um princípio básico e médio
conseguir fazer isso aqui tá chato olha
espanhol o outra pergunta que vocês
perguntam muito tempo não responder é
para o que vai fazer na bola e quando
ficar grande quando consegue ficar mais
velho ou quando começará a chegar muito
o contrário tipo pra ficar gorda grande
fazer lobby por que eu vou ficar
agressivo só fará tudo controlado até
enquanto o bebê dá para tratar muito bem
deu é muito calminha muito bem mas como
vocês sabem comentou já muita gente
quando quando podem ficar grande vai
ficar se um pouco agressivo é natural o
pai então vai precisar de estar com
outros animais cachorros têm poucas
cabras outros boto é professor se é que
vai me relaxar nem sei que vocês me
entendem
eu não posso ver e eu sou afirmou
francis silvy já o que faço agora eu vou
deixar o blog nem irmã porque ela tem se
uma casa muito grande tem uma quinta
gigante então eu vou deixar o all boys
enquanto não vou andar nem lógico nós
mesmo vai protestar la à vontade e vai
estar feliz da mesma porque ela vai
tratar muito bem deu eu espero então é
esse que vai conduzir a bola e sempre
que for viajar ou sempre que precisar se
de que o de não conseguir um bom comigo
se eu precisava relaxar também tenham
ajuda os amiguinhos de lula no campo da
comunidade daqui quando é que o traço
conectar a namorada 2 basicamente
pessoal como vocês leram pelo título foi
cancelado o que esta pergunta está
diretamente relacionada com a pergunta
da arquitetura namora esquema se deviam
ou não e sim eu sei que muitos de vocês
já sabem disso porque ela própria já fiz
isto explica a instituição ganhou vários
truques no ar para vocês o meu público
que sim já o nosso junto ao foi difícil
para mim não foi uma situação muito
complicada e vai explicar tudo o porquê
dessa relação teria acabado e agora não
vou vingar
não é qualquer só agora sérios e que
naturalmente muito vocês vão ficar
tristes por muitos você estipula duravam
de ver juntos mas nós temos duas
estrelas da internet e figuras públicas
nós também somos pessoas de pessoas têm
sentimentos 161 de que o tempo foi
passando ea vida que as coisas foram
acontecendo muita coisa boa aconteceu
nessa situação e muita coisa má
muita coisa horrível também aconteceu às
vezes eu preferia enfrentar assim
martelo fazer dentro do que eu sei que
você está bem para não ter que passar
por algumas coisas ou eu te jato suada
que só fala em estudo mas continua no
final do tempo normal da decisão e não
quiser de anunciar logo porque as coisas
ainda estavam assim mas sabem quando
fala quando vocês tipo então não tão más
por isso aconteça uma coisa
não acontece pois a estreia nesta minha
explicar isso mas basicamente nós
estamos juntos e continuamos amigos ela
no twitter diz que sim mesmo absoluto em
casa tudo entre nós já está tudo muito e
não se preocupe o pessoal tá tudo bem
simplesmente nós já não estamos na
relação que pneu furado namorado aí fui
mas voltando à pergunta quantos ao
conectar a namorada 2 oficialmente está
que soado quem sabe uma namorada nova eu
sei eu sei estados unidos pode me
irritar a idéia é estudar aqui nem que
seja a minha namorada não é assim não
quero um namorado a faca fazer dos
desenvolvedores ainda vai namorar comigo
mas ele é uma pessoa tarde condenou a
próxima pergunta que vocês um ponto
muito taquito está chateado cujo turista
casa dos rituais nem tanto
só vou ser muito sincero com vocês
não não acho que isso não a suspensão e
está à altura da casa do youtube foi uma
fase em que o pio dancinhas da casa e
essa fase giro assim alguma revolta por
parte das pessoas que vai estar ruim
quanto indo o número é o ronaldo nessa
fase um pouco falta de comunicação
porque nem nós que estivemos lá deus nem
eles perceberam bem o nosso lado então
ou aquela falta de comunicação que gera
sempre um pouco do problema e mesmo
antes de ter sido em casa eu já tinha
avisado e já tinha dito que este iria
acontecer em breve
ok mas como eu sempre controlar e como
eu sempre pude dizer não queria todos
pensavam que eu estava fazendo booth que
não estava para ser o iene estava para
ser com isso a decisão que eu tomei foi
devido a coisas que aconteciam dentro da
casa que eu não estava muito caí coisas
pessoais nossas coisas que não vou falar
aqui porque o crime já da vida pessoal
mesmo então é especial e uma bizarra e
usava pessoa não gosto estou sentido
triste
não quero aqui no qatar fc e essas
coisas foram faladas foram expostas mas
muitas vezes a nossa vida é muito
agitada e às vezes nós não conseguimos
entender bem
imaginem só 7 de outubro dentro de uma
casa e apesar de estarmos juntos cada um
tem a sua vida eo seu foco então essa
faz tempo de ser opção ficou um pouco
triste e é completamente normal esse é o
ritmo cai mas isso também não quer dizer
que nós tinham estilizados com muita
gente pensou a área que está em casa no
nosso estúdio amigas ai ai meu isso não
aconteceu assim foi tudo falar mas o
fato de comunicação só inclusive quando
hawking eu falei com o pessoal tudo está
tudo na boa mesmo e falamos mesmo dessa
situação que eu estou aqui a falar agora
está tudo bem inclusive windows que só
permite rodar campeonato mas não sei que
a minha marca
olha olha meu e quando eu expliquei o
que realmente tenha acontecido dos dois
lados e um possível não perecível
e foi isso que aconteceu e foi
comandante também ficou claro se tipo
pai falar sobre disparos e essas
pequenas coisas para nós quando não são
faladas tipo geram um golpe já era uma
tristeza no twitter vai ficar sem
bateria
mas o que muitos como eu estava dizendo
só ficou tudo vai estar tudo muito bem
entre nós eu continuo a ser amigo de
toda a gente para mim que um molecão
mónica é se pudesse comer tempo está
disponível a pergunta e na quinta do
conde no jogo dos membros da casa dos 8
bits
próxima pergunta que vocês perguntam
muito nas turmas bichinho anúncio sim o
ok eu acho que não há muitas mais
perguntas que possam explodir assim
vocês me perguntam muito que eu não
quero responder e dois só eu acho que
não justifica porque o espírito já sabem
que se quiserem que os torna mais
perguntas que vocês acham que eu não
quero responder
comentei em baixo e já sabem deixem
muito laquê neste vídeo o pai nosso que
no final risco renan e só os que tenham
estado que desferiu fiquem bem até
apróxima